-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor
you know from his work
in "Lovecraft Country,"
"The Harder They Fall,"
and Marvel's "Ant-Man
and the Wasp: Quantumania,"
which is in theaters now.
He also stars in "Creed III,"
which opens in theaters
and IMAX March 3rd.
Let's take a look.
-I was the best, though.
-Yeah, you were.
-I was, bro.
But I never got a chance
to prove that.
Look, all I'm saying, bro...
if Apollo Creed could take
a chance on some underdog...
...why can't you?
-Please welcome back to the show
Jonathan Majors, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I mean, I --
I don't usually
go out of my way to say this.
I am digging your outfit
a great deal.
-Whoa!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you!
It feels like --
I feel like this is, like,
a '70s talk show right now.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Good old-school vibe.
-We've got our tea.
-Yeah.
-And now, I know you --
This is rare for a guest to
bring out their own cup.
But this is -- I've heard you
talk about this,
this is inspired by something
your mother told you?
-Yes, don't let nobody else
fill you up, boy.
-Uh-huh.
-That works many ways,
doesn't it?
[ Laughter ]
But she was talking about
self-esteem and respect
and, you know,
what this world can do to you.
You know,
someone can big you up,
and people can tear you down.
But the cup is a metaphor
of, you know,
you can only do that yourself.
-You can only
fill up your own cup.
It's a good thing
for all of us to remember.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Another thing to remember
is to not chew gum
on public television.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, here.
There you go. You can --
I would --
-You sure?
-Yeah, it's my cup.
you can go for it. Do it.
There you go.
We take care of our guests here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-We're officially brothers now.
-Yeah, we're officially
brothers.
We're cup brothers.
-Cup brothers.
[ Laughter ]
This is getting weird.
-Doesn't sound right.
I thought it before I said it,
and I didn't realize
how it would sound.
[ Laughter ]
-Perhaps we play
on the same baseball team.
-Yeah, that's true.
[ Laughter ]
We played on the same baseball
team that was short on gear.
[ Laughter ]
And you -- you would bat first,
and then depending whether
or not you were on base,
we'd go to the back --
not important, yeah.
Hey, so last time we talked,
it was on Zoom.
You were in London working
on "Ant-Man," now it's out.
-Now it's out.
-It must be so nice when you,
especially when you work on
one of those Marvel movies
where people know what
you're doing,
can't tell them
any of the details.
-Right.
-Is it rewarding
that people
can now experience it?
-There was a Kang, it was in the
bag, now it's out of the bag.
-It's out of the bag.
-The Kang is out of the bag.
-Kang's out of the bag.
-Yeah, so --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it feels really good.
You know what I mean?
It's a diary.
It's seven months of your life
and prep.
And people saying,
"What you doing?"
Saying, "Oh, nothing, bro."
[ Laughter ]
You know?
"What you doing in London?"
"Hmm, hanging out," you know?
But, yeah, now it's out,
in the world, it's in cinemas,
it's doing great
at the box office.
-That's very exciting.
-I'm happy, yeah.
-And now, you're actually
in a film that has a chance
to maybe knock your other movie
out of the number-one slot.
And this is, you know --
this is,
you know,
the "Rocky" cinematic universe.
And these movies, I think
there's a lot of responsibility
to be in them because
they are so inspirational.
-Yeah.
-And have been
from the very first one.
-Yeah.
-Were you someone that,
when you saw him as a kid,
you were inspired
by those movies?
-Extremely.
-Yeah.
-"Rocky I"
is just a piece of art.
-It really is.
It's a perfect movie.
-It's just incredible.
And the story, you know,
Sly and how he got it made.
Now in adulthood I go,
"Wow, that's incredible."
The "Creed" films,
"Creed I," I think --
I was living in New York City?
Yeah. Between schools.
And I joined Equinox...
[ Light laughter ]
Yeah.
...but was not working.
Was not -- Was not an actor.
You know, I was trying to
get to grad school.
So, I could not afford Equinox.
-Yeah.
-So, that's okay.
And then "Creed II"
was extremely inspiring.
Brought a bunch of guys
over to watch it.
You know, I was in grad school
at the time.
Yeah, but that was --
those, um...
the montages, that's the --
that's the kicker.
-Yeah. Those montages --
and I think there's --
any thing you're about to
take on in your life,
you go back and watch
any "Rocky" montage,
you're more prepared.
-You're ready. You're ready.
You're ready. That was really
the pressure for the film.
-And Michael B. Jordan,
true story,
called you personally
to ask you to do this, yes?
-Hit me on the iPhone.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And did you answer right away?
Did you have his number?
Did you know who it was?
-I did not have
his number right away.
He hit my manager and friend,
she said, "Hey,
Michael B. Jordan
wants your phone number."
I said, "Oh, no."
[ Laughter ]
-Are you someone
who usually gets in trouble?
-Always. That's exactly it!
You nailed it!
Always in trouble.
'Cause I was like,
if anybody wants to call me,
I've done something.
-Right.
-So, I'm thinking,
"Okay, who did I --
No, I'm okay, I'm okay."
-Yeah.
-But, yeah, he called me.
20 -- 20 minutes into it
I'm nodding my head, you know.
It's a boxing match.
The pitch.
You know, he's saying things.
I'm going, "Hm, hm, hm,
that sounds good.
Ow, take that," you know?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And at the end of it, after
maybe 45 minutes, we hung up.
20 minutes later,
I called him back.
I said, "Hey, man,
let's roll, let's do it."
-That's fantastic.
-Yeah. Yeah.
And now, of course,
this is the kind of role,
and again,
you've been in series movies
where, you know, there's a
physical fitness element to it.
I've read how seriously
you took it.
But there has to be --
I mean, I've seen pictures.
The only way
you can take it is seriously
if the goal is to look like that
at the end.
-Yeah, you must.
-Yeah.
-You must. I mean --
-You can't show up
on the first day and be like,
"You guys have CGI, right?
You're gonna...?"
[ Laughter ]
-That's the other franchise.
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Yeah, yeah. This is a --
I mean, that's like --
that's, like, the thing.
You never know --
I mean, you're an entertainer.
You never know what it is that's
going to come across your desk.
-Yeah, I know
it's not going to be
"Do you want to be
in our boxing movie?"
[ Laughter ]
-But it might be the --
-Well, Michael B. Jordan
called me,
and I was like, "What?"
And he goes, "Do you have
Jonathan Majors' phone number?"
And I was like --
[ Laughter and applause ]
But, yeah, you never know.
-Yeah, you never know.
And I mean -- Sly Stallone,
Sylvester Stallone, you know,
Michael B. Jordan, you know,
all the folks that have
done these films,
that montage is everything.
-Yeah.
-You know, it's everything.
So yeah, you got tip-top shape.
I was like a year --
a year and a half,
year and a half of training,
you know.
-Wow.
-Up until that day.
-Did you -- After that day,
did you have --
did you give yourself
a cheat day?
Was there any enjoyment?
-No, I -- Yes, it was --
I mean, getting up those ropes
was a lot of fun.
-Right.
-Especially once you
got up there.
-Yeah.
-But, no, right after that,
I shot this other film
called "Magazine Dreams."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And that's a --
that's a body builder,
and that's
whole different level of --
-When are you going to play
somebody who's just, like,
letting himself go?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
-Give it a few years.
Yeah, later in your career,
maybe later.
-Yes, soon. Soon I hope, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I got a lot more questions
for you.
We'll be right back with more
from Jonathan Majors, everybody!